all right it is time to take a look at
the
super wild card awards uh we've done
that every tuesday all season long
shireen williams mds and i go through
offensive player of the week defensive
play of the week rookie the week coach
of the week we're going to do it now mds
we welcome him in i have a feeling that
our three box isn't working today so
it's going to be interesting to see how
we work this out with all three but mds
hello to you and let's get right to it
offensive player of the week for the
super wild card round there he is mds
what do you got
well i've got lamar jackson who had
another double triple which of course
means more than 100 yards both running
and passing and i liked the attitude he
displayed he reminded me a little bit of
michael jordan saying i took that
personally with the way he seemed to
really want to prove that no i am not a
playoff joker and yes i can win a big
game he won a big game in a big way and
i think we're going to see a lot more
playoff wins from lamar jackson for many
years to come
speaking of a lot of postseason wins mds
you're one of the best stat people i
know and one of my favorite stats from
last weekend was tom brady was starting
his 42nd postseason game the bucks were
pl as a team as a franchise were playing
in their 16th postseason game it was
their first win since 2002 their seventh
postseason win in history tom brady of
course is 31 and 11 in his postseason
career and he was outstanding in this
game he had the fourth most yards he's
ever had in any postseason game 381
yards threw for two touchdowns if he
keeps playing like that they've got a
good chance to beat the saints this
weekend mike
josh allen last year
would have lost on sunday or saturday
excuse me to the colts because the colts
outplayed the bills josh allen this year
with the confidence he's developed the
performances we've seen the growth that
we've witnessed josh allen
offensive player of the week for me
because he was the difference with the
colts having 450 yards no turnovers they
should have won the game the bill's
defense wasn't great the running game
wasn't there but there's a calm there's
an assertiveness there's something
different about josh allen last year he
had that play where he was falling down
and through the touchdown pass last year
that's a fumble or an interception
that's not a touchdown because we saw
some goofy out of control play from him
in the postseason last year this year it
was special and you know to get back to
lamar jackson and tom brady to thread it
all together something i said earlier
today on pft live which i firmly believe
is we look for the next tom brady peyton
manning rivalry that continues to renew
itself year after year after year
the fact is there are so many great
quarterbacks in the nfl we're going to
have an assortment of great rivalries
and guys who are going to cross paths in
the playoffs from time to time and lamar
jackson and josh allen is a great one
potentially not that we're going to see
it every year but we're going to see it
and we're going to see patrick mahomes
and josh allen we're going to see
patrick mahomes and lamar jackson we're
going to see baker mayfield and josh
allen we're going to see all of these
various combinations of great young afc
quarterbacks as they progress through
their 20s and through their 30s and it's
a great thing for the national football
league to not have it all tied up in two
guys but to have a broader spread of
great quarterbacks who will have
games against each other in the
postseason all right defensive player of
the week for the wild card round the
super wild card round get it right mds
who do you have
well i could have chosen several players
from the ravens defense but i decided to
go with derrick wolfe who had
six tackles of derek henry also had a
sack on ryan tannehill and you know
derek henry had 18 carries for only 40
yards which was his lowest output of the
year but i actually think even more
important than that he didn't have a
single rushing first down and when you
think of a player like derek henry what
do you want from him in the playoffs you
want him picking up first downs and
moving your offense down the field the
ravens completely prevented him from
doing that i thought derek wolf among
many players who just had a phenomenal
game he said after the game that he
relished the opportunity the physical
challenge of tackling derrick henry he
did a great job of it
mds i didn't think the rams had a chance
against seattle unless they could score
a defensive touchdown or special teams
touchdown well guess what they did just
that they were up 6-3 when darius
williams does what darius williams does
against
russell wilson he intercepted him this
time it was a pick six read the screen
beautifully and returned it 42 yards to
the end zone which was the key play in
that game and guess what
dk metcalf couldn't chase him down
either take that buddha baker but he's
intercepted russell wilson three times
this season he had five total
interceptions three of them came against
russell wilson i think russell wilson
needs to quit throwing against him no
touchdowns against him and a 26.5 passer
rating when throwing at darius williams
this year so next year russell wilson
picks somebody else maybe jaylen ramsey
instead of darius williams
i'm not nearly as enthused about college
football as i used to be for a variety
of reasons that aren't really we don't
have time for me to get into it here and
this year with the pandemic and all that
i cared about it even less but i'm a
supporter of west virginia great carl
joseph who was disappointing during his
early career with the raiders he was a
first round draft pick getting his
second life with the browns i think i
made him a defensive player of the week
at some point during the regular season
i've made into defensive player of the
week for the wild card round right place
right time right attitude right mindset
to go get the ball when marquis pouncey
snapped it past ben rothsberger on the
first play from scrimmage on sunday
night it's almost like roethlisberger
and james connor didn't want to run into
each other nobody committed to go get
the ball in a moment like that of
confusion and chaos you just go get the
ball and that was the first domino that
triggered that 28 nothing outburst by
the browns they held on i think if there
would have been another 15 minutes in
the game the steelers may have caught
the browns but joseph started that that
landslide and he deserves credit for
getting on the ball when others were
wondering what the hell was going on so
congratulations to carl joseph it's time
for the rookie of the super wild card
round mds who you got
well we don't often talk about kickers
in our weekly awards but i wanted to
mention bill's kicker tyler bass who
went two for two on field goals one from
46 yards one from 54 yards you know bass
was a six-round draft pick drafting a
kicker is always a little risky but when
you're the bills and you're drafting a
kicker what you are thinking is
is this a guy who's going to make a 54
yarder on a cold and windy day in
buffalo in the playoffs if we need him
to and bass answered that question that
that was why
you use a draft
pick on a kicker tyler bass's game this
weekend
mds i said that the rams needed a
defensive touchdown they also needed a
good running game with the quarterback
situation as it were john wilford of
course left in the first quarter after
being hit in the neck and head area and
then after that jared goff came in with
his injured thumb and cam acres was the
answer to that offense outstanding game
by the rookie 28 carries 131 yards and a
touchdown he also had two catches for 45
yards just really did
an outstanding job in his first playoff
game mike
patrick queen the ravens linebacker the
guy from lsu who's had a very very good
season not good enough to be defensive
rookie of the year because that's chase
young's award but i go back to what mbs
was saying as it relates to derek wolfe
and the ravens defense and having those
linebackers who were able on the
interior portion of the scrum get to the
hole and help get derrick henry on the
ground even though queen only had two
tackles clogging things up and making it
impossible for henry to get ahead of
steam that's the flaw in his game he
needs two or three steps before he's at
full capacity so you swarm and you get
to him and you plug those lanes and you
keep him from getting to a spot where he
has the momentum to either run through
you or run around you and patrick queen
was a big part of that team effort aimed
at shutting down derrick henry and
delivering the ravens to the divisional
round all right coach of the week super
wild card round edition mds you're up
well alex van pelt took over offensive
play calling with kevin stefanski
watching the game from home and i
thought van pelt did a great job and
what i particularly liked is he didn't
get overly conservative it would have
been tempting you're an assistant coach
taking over for the head coach you don't
want to screw anything up it would have
been so tempting to say okay we've got
an early lead let's just sit on the ball
go nice and conservative they didn't do
that they were still taking some shots
and they ended up needing more than the
28 points they had in the first quarter
i thought alex van pelt did a phenomenal
job of keeping that offense rolling all
game
you're absolutely right mds and i was
trying to figure out if they could just
run the ball the rest of the way if they
could run out the clock but they weren't
conservative my choice is sean mcvay so
i think i've got the slot machine rams
because this is my third ram of the day
but you know on sean mcvay you can
question his you can question his
quarterback choice and and i'm sure
that's been done all over the world
probably even by jared goff you can
question
why he didn't have a third quarterback
on the roster with his number two
quarterback jared goff banged up but you
can't question his success and he has
been very successful since he's been
with the rams four seasons three
postseason appearances and just done an
outstanding job he's never had a losing
record and he did a very good coaching
job in a game this weekend that nobody
gave them a chance to win with their
quarterback situation as it was
well we complete the slot machine with
the ravens from derek wolfe to patrick
queen to the guy who was in charge of
the victory
that the ravens got and look this was
i think a very difficult spot for john
harbaugh because they lost to the titans
convincingly in the division around last
year at home they lost to the titans at
home in the regular season in overtime
and there was that whole issue with john
harbaugh approaching titans players like
aj brown aj brown told me after the game
i didn't know what was going on a coach
is going to approach players like he
wants to fight and then he gets into it
with mike fraible and mike vrabel very
dismissive go coach your team go coach
your team you know harbaugh had to
strike the right balance get the right
attitude not be too emotional and also
go into nashville as the favorite that
was a huge benefit for the titans when
it comes to the standpoint of developing
a chip on your shoulder wait a minute
wait a minute we're the better team
we're the higher seed we've beaten these
guys twice and we're the underdogs
harbaugh got past it pulled it all
together and got the ravens to focus and
also presided over that effort that came
up with the right plan for shutting down
derrick henry to the point where
if i'm the jaguars the texans the cults
next year that's my blueprint for trying
to slow down derek henry if i'm anybody
who plays the titans in the future
that's what i'm going to try to do i'm
going to mimic what the ravens did
because i need to get to derek henry and
knock him off his feet before he can
kill me the ravens pulled that off
easier said than done but they pulled it
off and because of that they're moving
on and they have a very good chance i
think to beat the bills coming up on
saturday night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports